so describe the first time kind of the
spark reading a little America story
when you knew this could be a TV show
what was the forum ember I don't I feel
like it wasn't we had dinner with the
Eisenberg who's a pal of ours who kind
of brought this idea to us and he I
remember him just kind of telling us a
couple of stories like vignettes the
rock rock when I think the first one
which is the episode that we wrote with
Lee Eisenberg that is the story I
remember the most because I thought it's
such a it's like so poetic it hurts
of like this guy the American dream and
this guy who's buying a piece of
property that has this insurmountable
obstacle on it and it's just man versus
rock so I feel like that was the first
one that really got me yeah I just said
that that was such a specific story that
I had never been told you know nobody
has done a story about how to like break
a rock on a piece of land I think many
Ronnie / Dwayne Johnson's movies yeah
how to break the rock and none of them
succeed yeah we got never do that pun
again well that is it news that little
America is in the Dwayne Johnson verse
we would love to have do it Dwayne
Johnson to the little American
University I mean that would be great
Dorie we should tell the story yeah
we'll give you partial credit oh thank
you so much executive producer would be
great so what was it like working coming
from working on the big sick which is
your personal life story to adapting the
very personal life story of other people
I think what we got out of our movie was
a real sense of the sensitivities
involved in in adapting your own story
and also a sense of just because it is
the factual what happened doesn't mean
that it needs to be in the fictionalized
version so I think those were those were
the two of the things that I think we
brought to this of adapting these
people's stories while being sensitive
to who they are and also understanding
these stories are inspired by you know
stories an art direct these have to be
good at
so TVs will have to change some stuff
while staying true to the emotionality
of the person's experience so that's
that's sort of what we were able to
bring to it was being Precious about
certain things but not being Precious
about other things there are a lot of
conversations we had about our movie
would be like but this was really
important to us and then someone that we
were working with our director or
producer but it's boring what would be
like yeah nobody wants to see that in a
movie but and then they would go well
why is that why was that so important
what was it about that that was so
important and then digging down to what
that emotion was and then finding a more
like narrative ly appropriate and
appropriate way to tell that and explain
that emotion was something we kind of
got out of our movie that we probably
were able to bring to this project yeah
that makes sense where the two of you in
dialog with the real people who inspired
these stories not directly but we had
people who were talking to them and
there would be times where it'd be like
okay so we need a little more detail on
there so you'd get stuck in a store and
be like let's go to the real person so
so we were always in directly in contact
with the subject but we need to speak to
them first it kind of depended on their
what they're wanting to be involved some
of them were like here it is no get out
here they were like here's the story do
whatever you want and then some were a
little more interested in wanted to just
sort of check in during the process I
was just taken aback by how much depth
was contained in each half-hour episode
were there any challenges condensing
these stories to a half an hour without
that you was gonna made it well for
instance in the rock episode he also in
real life the guy is a hang-glider as
well and so he would say that whenever
he had a truck he had trouble with the
rock he would like fly over it and it
looks so small from up there you'd be
like oh it's not so big for love here I
could handle it that's it was just too
much the roller skating was his the the
quail legs was his like all the hits so
many different the honey all the he had
so many hustles going on her note for
him is he's too interested he was we
were like it just feels like something
you were right
so that was one that at some point we
were like it's so great but it just
doesn't fit it like makes it too
amorphous
it's and I think to like it's a thing
we're like you want to I'm sorry I just
lost my completely I was thinking about
everybody all of these people that
they're inspired by they all have their
own life stories and the life stories
contain a million things we only have
time to tell a very small segment of
this a story that's inspired by your
story so yeah a lot of really great
stuff got left out of people's actual
lives but that's just kind of what you
have to do yeah yeah for sure what were
some of the challenges or sensitivities
that came from telling stories from
folks who had different identities from
you while we oh that's why we wanted to
get writers and directors as much as we
could who had connection yeah connection
to where these characters were from who
could speak the same language and we got
actors who could all speak those
languages so so that's mainly what it
was we got the right people and we made
sure that and we listened to what they
had to say if somebody was like hey this
feels off
then like yeah absolutely let's make it
let's find a way to make this kind of
feel right yeah and we wanted to use the
music from that part of the world and
and we we just basically got people who
knew that stuff and we trusted them yeah
what do you think ultimately this show
says in kind of our sort of fraught
contemporary conversation about America
right now
what's fraud about it today was like
that traffic was kind of bad yeah
exactly but crushing it no problems no
notes what does it say about America I
think it's you know it's this still
obviously as you said the immigration
Asst issue is something that people have
very passionate feelings about on
whatever side you're on but that the
idea that america is the land of
opportunity is still very real to a lot
of people and it is a land of
opportunity for a lot of people
sometimes it can be it's harder for
certain people than it is for others but
you know that that possibility is is
still there I think everyone regardless
of where you were born everybody is
looking for love friendship a job that
they dig
everybody's kind of searching for
similar things and I that's what I would
hope people would get out of this that
even they'll see people that are kind of
have their same insecurities their same
fears reflected on screen even if those
people are not from the same place that
they are